views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program
and do not necessarily reflect the views
and opinions of eight news now or next
our media group
i'm worried that we don't get a handle
on it but my hopes are that we do get a
handle on it
tonight on politics now fema in las
vegas how teams are trying to help
reverse a spike in covid cases here plus
we find that that's actually got
widespread support
we talked politics with anthony salvanto
from cbs news
new polling on election reform
coronavirus and the economy
and i get a call saying
your dad is dead turning heartbreak into
action congressman stephen horsford
tells us how his own father's murder
is behind a bill meant to help break the
cycle of violence
from eight news now this is politics now
[Music]
thank you for joining us masks are back
and so is a renewed push to get
vaccinations into arms
right now crews from fema are in las
vegas going door to door to help combat
our rise in cobit 19 cases
health and human services secretary
javier becerra was here to highlight the
effort
joe moller shows us what they're doing
more than 99 percent of those who are
dying today from covid
are unvaccinated secretary of the
department of health and human services
xavier becerra and governor steve
siselek joined forces to address the
recent rise in copen 19 cases in
southern nevada
those variants are going to keep coming
if we don't get ahead of this
thursday becerra shared how the federal
government is here to help
fema has sent surge response teams they
are canvassing certain hard-hit zip
codes throughout las vegas to pass out
vaccination information
thank you for doing this for going out
there
and touching people where they need
where you need to find them because
sometimes they can't come to us
he says these teams are here at
syslock's request and they're focusing
on the areas
uh in particular that have extremely low
vaccination rates and that's where
they're going and
we're putting up pop-ups and then
sending the cert teams in to help with
that
surge teams are being sent to a number
of cities experiencing spikes
syslack and visera visited a pop-up
clinic at the sherman gardens community
center
both say getting more people vaccinated
at clinics like this
will help combat the rising cases and
hospitalizations we are experiencing
well i'm worried that we don't get a
handle on it but my hopes are that we do
get a handle on it right now with like
they say having the surge teams here
fema on the ground is definitely making
a big big difference joe moeller 8 news
now
the workplace mask mandate here in clark
county is in place until at least
august 17th and then clark county will
reassess
now we often talk about vaccination
rates here in nevada as a whole but we
decided to see this evening
to take a look at how other counties
across nevada are doing with
vaccinations
clark county is at about 40 percent
fully vaccinated
washoe county up north in reno 56 and a
half percent of the population is
vaccinated
story county is the lowest on friday
just 11.7 percent of that population was
vaccinated
white pine counties at 38 percent for an
example and next
to next door in nye county the
vaccination rate is 33.6 percent
the federal eviction moratorium ends in
a week local shelters are preparing for
a tsunami of people that will need
assistance
the centers for disease control says
there will not be another extension of
the moratorium
so now local organizations are building
up their services to try and meet the
anticipated demand
both the salvation army and catholic
charities of southern nevada are adding
more case managers
they're encouraging people to reach out
for assistance because for many of them
this will be their first time without a
home
i know it's difficult when somebody
doesn't know what to do
like now you're faced with this you know
and you feel like
you have to solve it it's just reach out
and and then we'll see what we can do
the clark county carers housing
assistance program also known as chap
recently received more funding and it's
now accepting new applications for rent
and utilities assistance
there are currently about 2 000 beds for
homeless people in southern nevada
about 6 000 people are homeless many of
the debates across the country right now
are centering on election reform and how
elections should look
cbs news recently did a lot of polling
on how people feel about election laws
so i spoke with the survey and elections
director from cbs news anthony salvanto
and we discussed that
a lot to digest right now with regards
to voting changes and laws not only
here in nevada but nationwide and
joining us to talk about
that and other topics that are happening
right now the cbs news director of
election and surveys anthony salvanto
anthony thank you for joining us to talk
about uh
a lot of breakdown a lot of numbers and
kind of what the the public is seeing
with regards to some of the changes at a
local level
let's let's talk about the changes for
elections most americans
they're for expanding access to voting
early voting they think it might make it
easier
possibly that's more of a democratic way
of thinking what are some of the numbers
that you've seen
showing about that opinion about that
process hey john and great to talk to
you
so the first big thing for context is
coming out of 2020 you'll recall a lot
of states
put into place some changes to
ostensibly make voting more convenient a
little bit
easier for people obviously in the
middle of a pandemic and we saw a record
turnout
so one of the things we found when we
asked people
about this including a large segment
not just our poll but of validated
voters people we know
actually did go out and vote in 2020 is
that a majority
say that those changes ought to be kept
in place that those conveniences that we
saw added last year
so we get big numbers for that and the
other thing i will add to you
for you john is that in general in
principle
we find more people saying that the
voting process as it is
ought to either be easier or kept as it
is
both of those numbers outweigh the
people who say that voting should in
principle be
harder and finally those folks who do
say it should be harder there you do see
a bigger partisan split you see a lot of
republicans
a lot of voters who supported former
president trump in 2020
really dominate among the ranks of those
who say it should be harder john
so that's on a broader scale it seems
like according to this
polling more people want easier access
to be able to take part in elections
we mentioned some of the laws that are
being passed across the country right
now
what is actually in those measures
limiting early voting for example things
along those lines and
what does the public think about that
yeah so a couple of things john one is
that we want to look at first of all who
it the
who people think would be helped or
impacted
by the changes in these laws as the
people see it
so the first thing is if you ask
republicans
what happens if voting gets easier a lot
of the majority of them say
they think it'll help democrats win so
you see the politics in play here
and then if you go and you ask democrats
what happens if voting gets harder
a majority of democrats think that will
help
republicans win so to some extent the
partisans rank and file partisans
have absorbed their party's messages on
this and to some extent they see
politics
in play about who gets advantaged and
who doesn't
now let me add some specifics to this
about things like favoring voter id
in our new polling we find that that's
actually got
widespread support in that it's not just
democrats and republicans who favor that
in principle
but it also goes across white voters
black voters hispanic voters all with
large majorities saying
they would favor the idea of voter id
the other thing to add john is that
there is a lot of talk
about mail balloting about whether or
not all voters ought to be
sent a ballot whether male voting works
or not
and there we do see more partisan splits
where
republicans have been more suspicious or
critical of
mail balloting and that we see directly
coming from the fact that a
many more republicans voted in person
than democrats who use more mail ballots
in 2020.
republicans think that more voter access
is damaging to their
uh point of view whereas democrats think
it's it's beneficial
how much is that perception versus
actual reality
and i don't know if there's a way to to
gauge that necessarily but
on the ground is that true the reality
john
is that there is not a strong
association
between places where turnout goes up and
which party necessarily does better
you can find counties and you can
certainly find states where
turnout went up and former president
trump
or republicans in general did better and
you can find places where turnout went
up
and democrats did better and you can
also find the reverse in places
there weren't many where turnout went
down so it's a
loose association at best and the other
thing i would add just for context is
that when we look at turnout going up
and down
we often equate that with is voting
easier or is it harder it's not
necessarily the case
it is often the case and academic
studies and scholarly
studies have often shown that to a large
extent there are other factors there's
excitement about an election there's
whether people have voted in the past
voting becomes a habit
all that go into that turnout equation
so
this is one piece of the puzzle but it's
not
all of the pieces and so that actual
voting process
may have some effect but it's not
necessarily the dominant one john
yeah i think they say all politics is
local to some extent
what is the perception of president
biden's handle of the economy what his
administration is doing to get through
the pandemic
so the president gets overall positive
approval numbers for handling the
economy not as hard as he gets not as
high as he gets for
handling the pandemic but nonetheless
positive people say their personal
finances a majority of people
say that they're good but there are real
concerns notably
inflation we ask people the price you
pay for things is going up
and in fact large majorities 80 percent
saying the price of gasoline has gone up
for them
nearly as many saying the price of
groceries is gone up for them
electricity and power as well so that's
one
lingering concern there about the
economy
and the other thing if you talk about
spending you ask about government
spending
there is large support in principle for
a lot of these
infrastructure ideas building and
repairing roads and bridges for example
now this becomes a little more partisan
when you attach president biden's name
to it
that drops support a little bit among
republicans but in principle
the idea of infrastructure remains
very popular john and we'll see how
those measures work their way through
capitol hill that is an ongoing process
anthony salvanto from cbs news thanks
for bringing down the numbers for us we
appreciate it and we'll see you again
soon
let's talk more numbers a poll released
by governor steve sisilak's campaign
shows most nevadans still have a
positive image of him
and senator catherine cortez masto both
democrats are up for re-election next
year
so let's look at sisalak first and again
we'll point out this is from the siselak
team 78 of democrats viewed him somewhat
or very favorably independence viewed
favorably by 16 percentage points
however only 30 of republicans had a
favorable view of the governor
59 percent also viewed his handling of
the coronavirus
favorably this poll was done by oh
predictive insights
538's pollster rankings gave them a b or
c
grades with a slight republican bias
for metro police undersheriff kevin
mcmahill
says he now wants the top job this week
he announced he's running for clark
county sheriff
mcmahill is already endorsed by current
sheriff and gubernatorial candidate joe
lombardo
mcmahill retired from metro back in
december after 30 years with the
department
former assistant sheriff and current
state assemblyman tom roberts has also
told 8 news now he's running for the top
job
next on politics now dealing with gun
violence
now my job is to try to give somebody
else
an opportunity he didn't have
congressman stephen horsford talking
about the murder of his father
and how it helped inspire a bill that he
has right now in congress
welcome back to politics now
democratic congressman stephen horsford
is using his own story to push for a
bill to tackle gun violence
his father was murdered nearly three
decades ago now the congressman hopes a
new piece of legislation will prevent
other families from experiencing similar
trauma in an
exclusive interview he tells his story
to the i-team's david charns
someone chose violence and took his life
that doesn't have to be it's a moment
congressman stephen horsford says
made him passionate for change we're
talking about breaking
the cycle of violence so that no one
has to experience it a cycle of violence
that's affected his own family
starting when he was 19. it was trauma
for all of us for our entire family
you know i've again tried to turn that
pain into a sense of purpose
in 1992 a gunman shot and killed
horsford's father
at this north las vegas convenience
store your dad is dead
okay what am i supposed to do with that
that's 28 years ago
i am now in a position where i can do
something about that
he's introduced the break the cycle of
violence act which creates
community-based
intervention programs you don't give
them anything else to do what do you
want them
to do targeting young people at risk
teenagers like sean jerion
coleman i feel like if you get on the
face you'll change then
what are you doing coleman survived a
shooting two years ago
now he too is turning that scar
into new found self-confidence it's a
chance to
be the change you want to see that's
what i always say he's the president
of an advisory council here at nevada
partners
i was on the streets at 16 17 so it's
kind of like being in the streets you
know
you just learn you know you either adapt
or you die this is a poem for brianna
taylor i wrote
we fought long and hard in protesting
campaign to get your killers arraigned
but he's adapted in a different way it's
hard to explain why another innocent
black individual has to be slain
taking up poetry writing a new chapter
one in his life
in other lives too they plug you into
programs and
they put you they set you up with people
that could really help you
move into a path where you want to go i
didn't have the opportunity for my dad
to see me graduate from college
for him to see me get married for my
three kids to
have the chance to to meet
their grandfather for the congressman
it's about
investing in another way to reduce crime
and to prevent one's potential
from being stolen my job is to try to
give somebody else
an opportunity he didn't have
a trauma that i experienced that my
family experienced that too many family
members
in throughout southern nevada and i
i'd never want my community to be
labeled as pi
as violent democratic congresswoman dina
titus is a co-sponsor of the bill as are
48 other members of congress all of them
democrats
right now the bill is making its way
through two congressional committees
i'm david charns eight news now a recent
government report
finds gun violence costs our country
more than 200 billion dollars a year
about 700 dollars for every american now
as david mentioned no republicans have
signed on to this proposal
we did reach out to the national
republican party for a comment but they
declined
next on politics now las vegas trying to
woo
the oakland a's but where would a
baseball stadium go in the valley
ron futrell breaks down some possible
locations
and we hear from the head of clark
county school district as class
approaches on politics now you're
watching
politics now
[Music]
the clark county school district has
close to a billion dollars in federal
funding to spend
well i spoke with superintendent dr
jesus jarrah this week about how he
wants to use the money for ccsd we also
spoke about other issues in the district
this time last year there was a bit of a
divide that had developed between ccsd
and the state and governor sysolak with
regards to distance learning everyone
was kind of scrambling to try and make
things
happen at the school education level
what confidence do you have
from the state uh that they are uh
behind what ccsd plans to do
when it comes not only to federal
funding we'll get to that but also just
when it comes to getting kids in class
safely
well we've been working with the state
um you know since uh
we closed we you know opened schools in
march the state department the governor
the governor's office uh you know the
department of education worked closely
to open up in march they saw the
priority
we had you know our kids were struggling
at home our adults were struggling
everybody was so we
focused came together march one open
schools and
in our pre-k open you know for our
secondary schools and hybrid models so
they're very supportive we submitted our
plan to the state july 8th
that the board just approved and now
they're in line to where we are
and things have improved absolutely our
relationship has gotten a lot better and
you know believing where we're we're all
headed together where do you think the
most
need is right now well right now from
what we saw obviously i've been very
vocal about the mental health
of our students and our staff um you
know technology
we're going to continue moving forward
and the investment that we've already
made
our digital learning and that it's not
given just the key to computers how are
we teaching and learning
so we have those two are our priorities
and obviously
accelerating the learning our students
we don't know how
you know fall how far we fell
academically
and for us bringing our kids back in
front of our teachers where they belong
is accelerating learning that's a number
three priority for us
all right we go from school to sports
officials from the oakland a's have been
looking in las vegas at possible
locations for a ballpark if the a's
relocate here to southern nevada
sports anchor ron futrell takes a look
at some of the possible spots for the
a's here in las vegas
we've got a lot of empty spaces here in
the valley where a ballpark could work
30 acres would be
a tight fit 60 acres would be plenty of
room for a ballpark and plenty of
parking for locals
and that's important by the way we'll
show you a few general spots
that are being looked at first of all
let's take a look at oh in north las
vegas
up there across from the speedway at
i-15 a lot of blm land up there we'll
talk more about that in a moment
also near the va hospital is another
possible site
to look at way in the south part of the
valley all the way
out near the inn casino a lot of land
out there
where they could possibly find a place
to be able to put a ballpark
by the thomas and mack center near the
airport is another location
that we understand the a's are looking
at paradise and tropicana
and then finally the rock and rio site
okay this is a sahara
and las vegas boulevard south right
across from the sahara hotel
another spot that they are looking at we
understand right now but that north las
vegas location
a couple of locations out there mayor
john lee would like to make that happen
fifty percent of north las vegas has
been built out yet we have a lot of land
i've got a piece of property 450 acres
right now
that is a work a development zone that
we can put together a cross street can
be a
va hospital i have 135 acres
we could take that big 450 we could put
the stadium on it
we could put the practice fields on it
and we can put the executive offices on
it
one stop shop for the a's yeah well the
a's and las vegas have a great
relationship
they played regular season games and
exhibition games here in town the
aviators of course are the
aaa affiliate for the oakland a so they
certainly like las vegas a's management
they're in town
making at least their fourth trip to las
vegas today and tomorrow talking about
how to make this work if it can there
are a lot of moving parts
finding the right location is just one
part of it
so far government officials say they
don't want to spend any public money on
a new ballpark but if the a's put some
pressure in for
public funding there will have to be at
least one special session this year to
deal with redistricting they could
discuss it
you're watching politics now
[Music]
parent politics now a friendly reminder
that we are collecting school supplies
as part of our annual great school
supply drive it's pretty simple
if you donate just drop off your school
supplies at any smith's location around
southern nevada
through july 29th that is next thursday
all supplies go to the public education
foundation's teacher exchange program
help out if you can school has politics
too
thank you very much for watching
politics now you can sit and stay up to
date online at eightnewsnow.com
and don't forget you can watch us every
saturday right here on eight news now
thank you for watching have a good week
you